[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry PhD an
exfoliation fan today I'm going to be
talking about the size behind one of my
favorite exfoliant products peeling gels
how do they work is all that stuff that
comes off actually your skin if you like
this sort of video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel and make sure
you click the notification bar so you
don't miss any videos also if you want
me to talk about the science behind
other beauty products leave me a comment
telling me which products you want me to
talk about let's start by talking about
what exactly peeling gels are if you've
read my free exfoliation guide you'll
know that peeling gels are a popular
type of exfoliant product in Asian
skincare there are lots of really
popular peeling gels from brands like
cure and the face shop they start off as
a watery gel and then once you massage
it and spread it over your skin they
turn into little bits
but are those little bits rolled up skin
or are they just product this is one of
the cases where ingredient analysis
doesn't really tell us enough to say for
sure which one will be so I did a little
experiment to see if the fibers were
skin or product or a combination of both
I wore a pair of surgical gloves and I
tried massaging the gel so that I didn't
get any skin contact it was actually
really interesting when you massage it
initially there's not much product
rolling up but if you add a little bit
of oil like the oil that would normally
be on your skin then the bunching up
started to happen as you can see from
the little bits produced most of the
stuff that's coming off is most likely
product and some skin oils are combining
with it to form the little clumps but if
you look more closely at the clumps that
come from the glove experiment and the
clumps that come from skin there's a
little bit of gray stuff on the fibers
with the skin and that is the dirty skin
cells if you've ever used a peeling gel
on a flaky bit of your face you'll
notice that it's really efficient and
removing dead skin but it's not quite
efficient enough to rub off as much skin
as you think it is just from seeing they
mount that bunches up if you try the
glove experiment yourself make sure that
you're using something with enough
friction for the fibers to Ashley bunch
up when you're using a peeling gel on
your skin the water absorbs into your
skin and the oil from your skin makes
the fibers bunch up plus there's
friction between your two skin surfaces
which makes the bunching happen faster
if you're doing this on a different
material and you're missing one of these
components it won't work as well I also
thought it would be interesting to see
what the bits look like under a
microscope and here they are this image
is of the peeling gel product when I
rubbed it on the glove and this one on
the right is the one with the skin and
you can see that there's little bits of
gray which is the dead skin cells
this next bit is a bit gross but I
wanted to do this for science
I also rubbed off a bit of dead skin
from around my ankle without the peeling
gel and I put it under the microscope to
see what it looked like you can see that
the bits of peeling gel that I got from
rubbing it on my skin it looks a lot
more like the peeling gel by itself then
the dead skin by itself so it's safe to
say that most of it is probably the
peeling gel product and not just your
skin coming off so what exactly ins in
these bunched up bits of peeling gel for
most products is probably cellulose and
sometimes alkylate polymer usually these
ingredients are used to thicken up
products but if you put too much in then
will tend to bunch up when it's rubbed
on the skin
this means that peeling gels are like a
very gentle physical scrub instead of
the chunky bits of scrubbing particles
you have these soft cellulose chunks a
lot of peeling gels have enzyme a
chemical exfoliants and their
ingredients as well but you can't get
that much dead skin off that quickly
using those methods even with a really
strong chemical peel it takes a few days
for the skin to slowly come off another
youtuber made a cool video about cure
aqua gel and whether it was a chemical
exfoliant she referenced me in her video
and she concluded that it was a chemical
exfoliant she tested the product with
oil on a ceramic plate and that she
tested the balled-up bits for protein I
use cure aqua gel as well in one of my
glove experiments and I did get balled
up bits unlike her and I think the
reason her conclusion is different is
because she tested the product on the
ceramic plate which didn't have enough
friction for it to punch up the protein
test she use which is very cool by the
way also doesn't really test if the
balls are all skin it shows that there's
some skin coming off which would be the
case with a physical exfoliant if you
look at the ingredients of the Cure aqua
gel it also doesn't have any ingredients
that could act as the chemical exfoliant
plus there's the fact that chemical is
folios don't act that fast and acrylate
SAR the third ingredient from the top so
based on what we know about how these
ingredients interact with skin I don't
think it could actually act as a
chemical exfoliant but this doesn't mean
that peeling gels don't work or that
there
why they're actually really really good
gentle physical exfoliants still I
personally love feeling gels some of my
favorites are from its skin which I've
reviewed in a past video about my
empties I also really like the faceshop
white jewel I've been using Kure aqua
gel as well and it's quite good but I
don't think it's really good enough to
justify the higher price that I can get
it for although maybe I'll work
differently for you so in summary
peeling gels aren't really good chemical
exfoliants they're mainly physical
exfoliants if you're after a chemical
exfoliant or if you're not sure which
exfoliants you should be using on your
skin you can check out my video on
exfoliation and you can download my free
exfoliation guide as well if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to my channel
I'm also an Instagram with more beauty
tips and you can check out my blog as
well see you next time for more beauty
science